stop by eight news now today is our
annual founders day we are helping local
non-profits with your donations and this
year we're supporting serving our kids
mary jane bellies are live right behind
us here at channel 8 the donation site
where people have been stopping by all
morning mary jane hello
john good afternoon we've been out here
bright and early at 6 a.m taking in
donations to benefit a wonderful
organization that is serving our kids
foundation they're really helping kids
here in the valley pretty much get an
after-school meal and weekend meals for
kids who would otherwise go hungry
without it we already have a few cases
of water here which is really important
as we know it is hot out in the summer
we also have some ramen noodles we have
a lot of non-perishable items that
includes canned goods we have donations
coming in right now you can already see
us loading up this truck cases of chips
here and also water we still need a few
items though like cheese and crackers
and oatmeal so again please come down
we'll be here until 6 pm to gather those
donations you can really help kids in
need our address is 3228
south channel 8 drive that's 3228 south
channel 8 drive again a really great
foundation here that you could help out
to help feed those kids we'll be out
here until 6 pm